are you trying to kill me Sean
what's going on everybody I'm Sean Evans
and you're watching hot ones it's the
show with hot questions and even hotter
wings and today we're joined by
legendary Outlaw and hero Puss and Boots
it's a pleasure Amigo today we'll be
tasting some real Scorchers so don't be
afraid to reach for that
milk that is some good legit very good
okay but we really should be saving this
for later nonsense how do you think I
got this fur on my chest
[Music]
foreign
catnip Bring It On
so puss you've fought monsters
throughout your adventures was there
ever a time that you felt nervous or
outmatched oh sorry I was dreaming of
something spicy I'll remember that you
said that now look at this five in a row
no bad if your thing is incredibly mild
sensation
love that confidence so puss cats
notoriously have nine lives but you're
on record as saying that this is your
last one yeah so explain that death okay
I hear death number six involves some
Mad Dogs I have no regret
death number three a little too much
leyche huh I'm telling you I can't
always lands on his feet what as they
say lecture before the cream is way too
extreme
and death number two is because you're
allergic to shellfish you know I'm on my
last life but a meal with three Michelin
stars only comes around once
so puss you're known for protecting the
innocent and helping the less fortunate
how do you stay inspired it's a Colleen
you know it um whoa actually feel this
one oh oh my whiskers are tingling a bit
yeah yeah be careful around your eyes a
dragon one set my eyes on fire I think
I'll be fine
August bread
trust me ogres are overrated
so in many ways your life or should I
say lives Follow The Arc of the classic
hero's journey but I'm curious was just
like an average day like for you yeah
yeah last sauce went straight to my God
I can feel my tail watch this
I feel nothing
dead Sean seriously look at me look at
me
son
uh because any other question will be
ridiculous right now oh tell me about
your partnership with Kitty softballs
puss are you okay puss
in Boots
are you okay
please you drank all the lay checks come
on
Studio do we have any more leche for
Puss and Boots
my kingdom foreign
well it's been quite a ride but we made
it Puss in Boots you're the bravest cat
I know you've defeated Giants you've
slayed dragons and today together we've
conquered the hot sauce Beast we did
indeed salute cheers
and now there's nothing left to do but
roll out the red carpet for you my
friend this camera this camera this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life this is how I die
at least you make it sound legendary
[Music]
[Applause]
keep it spicy if you dare